this next one is sort of a statement
and sort of a question wrapped in there
somebody coming from law enforcement and
i thought it was a
pretty informative statement based on
one of the other podcasts that we did
and it says this i currently work vice
but i've had my share of use of force on
the job
i quickly learned that you can't knock
everyone out
and that applying jiu-jitsu will reduce
injuries to you
and the suspect so this is what we
talked about last time whereas if
if my method of controlling you is to
strike you i'm gonna have to beat you
over and over again to get you to submit
whereas if i know how to do a chokehold
boom you're good back to the quote the
chokehold or carotid as we called it is
still permitted in our force policy
but only in an immediate defense of life
situation
basically using a chokehold is
considered deadly force
and equivalent with shooting someone
there was a time when the lapd saying
was when in doubt
choke him out in the 80s during the pcp
era officers were applying the carotid
choke on pcp
suspects daily during one of those
incidents
a male black died from the choke being
improperly applied
chief gates made the mistake of going on
national television
and saying that male blacks had a higher
chance of dying from the choke due to
their physical make
and larger adam's apple
as you can imagine this caused an
outrage
which in turn caused the department to
fall to political pressure
and make the karate choke almost
impossible to use
so when i kind of alluded to this on
that
last podcast that there's there's
exactly what happened a guy got choked
to death
there was political pressure chief gates
comes out and
says that and actually i went i went
online and researched this a little bit
he
made like every classic mistake you
could make
on this and
that's why they outlawed using
chokeholds
and and actually uh as i read through it
they
a bunch of them kind of how i referred
to rodney king beating
and said here you had guys just wailing
on this this
individual with with bats and sticks and
billy clubs or whatever
and it didn't stop him and they referred
to that that
when they looked at the chokehold being
used that's one of the major cases that
they say man
let us let people use the chokehold so
this doesn't happen
this guy goes on as a certified archon
which is
our constants for arrest and control
arkhan instructor
i feel the department taking away our
ability to use a rear naked choke has
caused many unnecessary
shootings and injuries to suspects
it saddens me to work for a department
that is being run like a poor
corporation instead of a police
department
so that's kind of the build up right
that's why i wanted to read it because
there was just good information in there
it is
very much in line with what we talked
about last time in
in police work and and also in you know
uh combat situations where you're
dealing with non-combative people
in a hostile environment in other words
you go into a building to capture a
terrorist and there's a
there's women in there or there's kids
in there there's teenagers in there
that are not combative but they're not
compliant either so they don't have a
gun you're not going to shoot them but
you got to get control of them
now it gets into the sort of the
leadership question here
how do i keep morale up and stay
motivated
when i have no faith in the leaders and
when the leadership has turned its back
on you time after time
the morale is at its lowest point even
lower than post 92
riots according to the old timers
we were trained in the academy to be
warriors
now the department doesn't allow us to
call ourselves warriors
only guardians this change in mentality
will sadly cause
only more bad shootings and more
officers getting hurt
so that's uh
you know obviously a tough situation and
like i said for the jiu-jitsu versus
striking i think this is spot-on the
jiu-jitsu and the grappling is
is a far superior way like i said of
controlling people
than striking is that's just a reality
now on the leadership front that
leadership question
for me
i i have my own
team right i got my people
the people that are around me that i'm
gonna buffer
all this bad morale and all this stuff
i'm gonna buffer it
away from my team i'm gonna make their
lives good
that's my goal and i'm gonna lead toward
what my ideal is
right i'm gonna lead toward what my
ideal is now in order to do that well
you gotta play the game so that you can
get more influence
if you don't go play the game you say
hey the bosses don't know what they're
talking about
bosses don't know what they're talking
about and we need to uh
you gotta play the game you so that you
can get more
influence and and
that means doing what you have to do
that that means not saying hey
our morale sucks and we don't have good
leadership no it means going okay
we're gonna move we're gonna move
forward here's the goal here's what i
think here's what i believe
hey by the way i'm gonna run this up the
chain of command i'm gonna
gather the data myself i'm going to do
the research
i'm going to do the administrative work
i'm going to study the cases i'm going
to present them and say
hey here's what's happening i'm going to
do that from an
unemotional situation just from pure
logic hey
we've had this many shootings we've had
this many incidents we've had this many
we've had this many uh suspects turn up
with with concussions
there's only one thing that causes a
concussion to a suspect it's getting hit
in the head
so if we're having you know 42 percent
concussion rate
maybe we could drop that down if we use
something that doesn't cause concussions
but still gives us control
you gotta you got to do that leg work
and make life good for the people that
work for you
and that's that's that that can be a
little bit hard to do but it's not that
hard
you know they your subordinates look at
you
as the guy and so the way you carry
yourself and the way you present
yourself and the morale that you have is
the morale that they're going to have
that's what they're going to see as the
way it is and i've i've
always viewed in a single team that with
the seal teams to have different vibes
in them
good and bad someone have good commands
and there's a
there's a new commanding officer every
two years of the seal team so
you get a new guy that comes in and he
might be a lot different than the last
guy
he might be really good he might be
really bad and you know what it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter to me in the seal
platoon as a platoon commander
or even has a squad commander or even
has an e5 and a seal platoon
meaning just one of the sled dogs i
don't care
what the upper chain of command cause
guess what we're gonna do things right
we're gonna make things happen now we're
not gonna disobey what's being told
but if we're being told something that's
wrong guess what we're gonna try and get
it we're gonna run up the chain of
command we're gonna be squared away
we're gonna play the game so that we can
make the changes that need to
be made because i care about the teams
just like this guy cares about the the
police department wants it to be a great
force
wants it to do the right thing and so
you gotta
take that attitude that
you control your part of the world
and the more you improve your part of
the world and the more
influence you gain the more you'll have
control over the big picture as well
there's no company no corporation that
maintains just superb morale all the
time it doesn't happen
you know peop every company every
business every unit every force every
team has ups and downs
and they have leadership that comes in
and takes over and that everyone
considers to be bad
and that's that's the way it is
but you gotta own your little piece of
the world
and then as you own your piece of the
world guess what everyone starts
performing well
and as you perform well you gain more
clout and as you gain more clout you can
influence real change and that's what
you're looking to do
so don't let don't let that leadership
that bad what you consider to be bad
leadership just don't let that permeate
into your head into your world
buffer your people from it and then do
what you can to build the best team you
can get
so that you can have more influence so
that you can change
that policies and the procedures that
you don't agree with
it's a long haul i know it yeah i don't
have a miracle solution for you man it's
tough
it's tough but that's that's that's the
world
yeah that's the world yeah especially
when when you're dealing with the
political elements of it
and then at the same time you have the
public eye on you
you know so
you know as far as exposure and stuff
like that it's
the newsman and just i think media in
general it's easy to to spread
all this negative stuff it's easy you
know so it's like one of those jobs
where it
in a big way it's um it only gets
attention when something's wrong is
going on you know yeah and i would take
advantage of a lot of this negative
press
because a lot of this negative press
like like uh this guy is saying
hey we're getting more shootings we're
getting more beatings well why is that
let's look at our procedures hey boss
you know what we used to use this
chokehold and we had
x amount of concussions we had x amount
of shootings
you could present the information in a
logical way that proves
what i know to be true what this guy
knows to be true what anybody that's
ever done this type of work before knows
to be true
right that is that there are certain
techniques that work better than others
and a choke hold and a grappling type
scenario
definitely works better to subdue
somebody then striking them in the head
repeatedly until they're knocked
unconscious that's just the reality of
it and no one can argue with that
and the only reason that they went
against it is for political pressure so
how do we
how do we defeat that we gain clout we
move
we continue to get influence we grow our
power
we we strengthen our allies we build a
coalition
and we go forward and we win and it
might take
three years it might take three months
it might take six years
this guy right here that wrote this
might need to be the chief of police
himself before he gets it done
yeah but he that's what he does yeah he
keeps on the right path and keeps moving
in the right direction
and does the right thing so that he can
get advanced he doesn't make a bunch of
emotional arguments against people that
have a bunch of power
and put himself in a bad seat for them
where they're looking at him like he's a
rabble rouser
no not a good thing yeah you got to
build you got to build the relationships
up the chain of command so that you
become respected so that people do
listen to you
yeah that's what you got to do that's
how you make it happen yeah
yeah man and on a on a side note the
the chokehold well jiu jitsu overall
isn't just submission hold
that's that's kind of in my opinion one
of the great things about jiu-jitsu
it's like i know it kind of seems that
way sometimes if you're not if you don't
do jiu-jitsu whatever you think oh this
guy knows jiu-jitsu oh he'll choke you
out he'll break your arm
you know um the kind of the glamorous
part of it
is the submission for sure but the every
other part of it is
control controlling the situation all
the way down to controlling the other
guys
so when you when you consider like just
just an uh a concept
of wrist control in jiu-jitsu when
you're rolling this on wrist control
just that alone will help will help you
in law enforcement just that alone no no
let alone the whole of jiu jitsu just
wrist control
that'll help you alone so you don't need
to necessary and i'm not saying so the
choke hold should remain bad i'm not
saying that i mean for someone to die i
mean i know this guy died because the
choke would
was applied incorrectly so i don't know
if he broke his neck or his
atoms up or something yes and by the way
if he had
if he was better at jiu jitsu right he
would have applied it put the guy to
sleep
and then coughed him and all been good
to go which happens all the time in
class by the way
in training guys get put to sleep all
the time i put to sleep i don't even
know how many times
a bunch of times for someone to die from
a choke from a
regular normal chocolate you got to
choke him for a long time yeah where
your arms will be so tired just from
choking him after he goes unconscious
you have to keep
choking him for a long time so it takes
a lot yeah really this is probably what
you said probably a crushed
uh hyoid bone i think it's called yeah
it's basically your adam's apple crushes
you shut your windpipe and the guy
didn't get a tracheotomy
in time yeah that is very very rare
if ever in jiu jitsu now i've had i've
i've seen it happen one time a guy
passed out and went to sleep
and someone was gay choking him and so
just kept cranking didn't realize that
he was out for a couple seconds in it
and it
uh hurt him so you do have to watch out
for
it but i mean that is so rare
compared to the amount of times that
someone gets hit in the head and gets
brain damage
i mean that just happens all the time
yeah yeah
and this jokes that you can actually do
that does that kind of stuff but again
if you know jiu jitsu
you know the positions you know the
moves you know the submissions if you
can do submission
and you're not panicking you feel very
comfortable on the ground you feel
very uncomfortable engaging in combat
you feel very comfortable engaging in
this
struggle you're used to it you do it all
the time so you're not freaking out
yeah you're not adrenaline just cranking
a guy in the head with a billy club
over and over again and what does he do
he puts his hands up
why because he's trying to fight me no
he's just trying to protect his head but
you think he's trying to fight you
and that's why you're hitting him even
harder yeah
so yeah it's a it's definitely a tough
situation
and and the way you win
on the ground in is with jiu jitsu and
the way you win this leadership
situation is also with jiu jitsu you
don't go and bang
heads with the chain of command that's
not how you're gonna win this fight
the way you win this fight is by doing
jiu jitsu against the leadership
and you get in with them and you gain
their trust and you make them think that
you're the man
and your team is awesome and oh by the
way i know our team's awesome
and we totally agree with this policy
and we've supported it only this policy
is working great in this other policy oh
you know what you got this one policy
here that's not so good
maybe we could do something to fix that
let me do some research
that's how you win you got to play the
long game it's so funny that that
analogy like
jiu jitsu right so because really what
you do is
establishing a good position right
establish a good position
knowing where to be and where not to be
you know where to put your weight or
where to put your
force and where not to put your force
you know yeah
and the other big pieces that in jiu
jitsu that i was
more referring to although those are all
correct and you have to do those but
it's also
hey you think i'm going to choke you but
i'm actually going to unlock you right
right right
like that's the setup that you flank
people and you attack them indirectly
right
you infiltrate and you you do things
indirectly instead of going and just
fisticuffs banging each other
war of attrition don't do that so
treatment yeah
leading up the chain of command i think
that's kind of a new concept
you know that's a that's a chapter in
the book yeah or it's actually a sub
chapter in the book but it's one that
people
always have a hard time getting their
head around because i always say like
my boss did whatever i want him to do
yeah and people don't understand that
that's the way it is when you build
trust you take the time and you build
the relationship
and you prove over and over again that
you're going to do the right thing in
the right situation
and that you're going to take
accountability and responsibility when
something goes wrong
and that you have a good head on your
shoulders and that you're not going to
get emotional about things and you do
all those things
and that you're driving and supporting
the mission guess what you're going to
get you're going to get supported which
means your boss is going to do what you
want them to do
yeah meanwhile you're doing the same
thing with down the chain of command
you're like just that down zack list
you're doing that same thing yeah it's
crazy
and because you just i don't know it's
today it doesn't seem as intuitive you
know
easiest excuse that anyone could ever
have
is hey you know what my boss didn't give
me what i needed that's why i failed
hey you know what our bosses won't let
us use chokeholds
right and therefore we can't accomplish
our mission well no guess what
i'm gonna make i'm gonna i'm gonna lead
up the chain of command and i'm gonna
get
my superiors to let us do what we need
to do to do it effectively because guess
what
the the leadership is aligned your
leadership is gonna be aligned with what
you wanna do
do you think that the leadership of the
lapd wants
you know uh vic or uh suspects
and perps to get your brain damaged or
killed no they didn't want that
they wanted they want them to be
arrested properly they don't want to
have lawsuits the whole nine yards
so if you're presenting something to
them that's going to improve them and
move them towards the mission
and support the ideals of what they're
trying to get accomplished
of course you're going to get supported
now you're going to get these little
political battles but those are just
part of the challenge
they're just part of making it happen
you know that's part of the jiu jitsu
yeah yeah when you roll with the guy
don't expect him not to fight back
exactly right